[Music]
foreign hello welcome to the pretty
intense podcast today on the show is
Donald Hoffman
get your thinking cap on he is a
cognitive psychologist he's a science
author and he's a professor at the
University of California Irvine his
research is around Consciousness so in
the interview we talked about what that
is what is reality what is this world
reality what is this human personal
reality and it just went off on a lot of
tangents on just what that could be what
that is what they're finding and to give
you a little insight like there are
there are essentially like monoliths
there are there are structures outside
of this time space reality that they
have found but it's essentially like
like looking at something you've never
seen before so there are a lot of really
cool emerging things like for instance
like uh that that this table is not real
unless you're looking at it like like
this table is not local like this this
like glass is not local like it's
everywhere and it's only there when you
look at it and so stuff like that so
what we talk about is just basically
what does that mean what is what it why
why search to find these answers and
um and what is essentially the point of
it all I hope you enjoy this
thought-provoking conversation about
reality and Consciousness and how that
plays into our life
so enjoy the show please hit subscribe
uh I'd love for you to share your
thoughts in the comments this is
definitely the kind of topic that there
could be a lot of conversation around so
have at it man when did your fascination
with Consciousness begin because like
when I hear you talk I'm like I just
have to keep listening well it started
in various ways uh you know first
through a church right my my dad was a
minister and so he was a fundamentalist
Christian Bible thumping kind of Pastor
um uh so but he was also he had a
master's degree in chemistry so he had
both some science and and a Christian
version of spirituality and so there
they're talking about
you know there's more to life than just
space and time and physical objects
there's the spiritual realm and so forth
but but and so that got me thinking but
then I got a lot of you know dogmatism
which made me then second guess the
whole thing you know it's hard to know
as a teenager do you have to throw the
whole thing out do you how do you figure
out what's dogmatic nonsense versus what
is an Insight that you really need to
keep for yourself and so I finally
decided I needed to you know figure it
out for myself and what I questioned put
the question to myself was are we just
machines are we machines or is there
something Beyond that's special about us
and I decided the the way to really nail
down that question would be to actually
understand what could machines do and
that seemed to me like artificial
intelligence would be the scientific
field so I wanted to do artificial
intelligence to just see so what can
machines really do and is there a
principal difference or not and so I I
ended up going to MIT and I was in the
artificial intelligence Lab at MIT and
also in the brain and cognitive science
department so I was looking at the human
neuroscience and human psychology side
of things on the one hand and then the
what what could machines do on the other
hand and what I was really trying to do
was to you know what AI impart and some
people in hayr are trying to do is to
build machines that mimic human
intelligence and human behavior now of
course tell me I just want to do
whatever they can to make an intelligent
machine but I was interested in in
machines that that sort of model human
visual perception and human cognition
more generally and so that was how I
sort of got into this whole
Consciousness thing you know as a human
being you know you you wonder what you
are and you get one idea at church plus
some dogmatism so you don't know what's
what and then from science you get
another point of view plus some
dogmatism so again you don't know what's
what and so I decided I had to figure it
out for myself wow that is a lot to
unpack with your dad I'm sure with
yourself was there an experience you had
that sort of or was there an epiphany
that you had at some point in time that
made you question
the information and the rituals or the
things that happen in a religious
setting was there an experience well
there was one I
as the I don't know maybe a 17 year old
or 18 year old I remember talking to the
Head Pastor I had an intellectual
question
yeah how dare you well and that was the
response that was he said to me flat out
something it was almost a quote said Don
don't worry about it just believe
and
that struck me as just the wrong answer
uh for this kind of question I mean
there may be some things that transcend
human conception as fine but this wasn't
one of them and so I mean I'd seen the
dogmatism and when you're raised in it
you don't know any different right if
you're a fish everything you know you
know water doesn't seem wet so so but
that one went over the line when I was
told not to question that stuck in my
mind is okay now I do need to question
and I do need to find out for myself
because I'm not going to get it I'm not
going to get straight answers here uh so
that was sort of a but it took me a long
time right you don't
you don't just walk away at least in my
case I couldn't just walk away from all
I I really had to find out there's
there's probably something there that's
right and there's probably something
there that's very very wrong and I I
decided you know I couldn't just be
crude and just throw the whole thing
away that seemed I I felt there was
something there in the religious point
of view but I also felt that there was
something really there in the scientific
point of view and the fact that they
were contradictory meant that I would
probably have to figure out what I like
from both and what I rejected from both
so it means you had to do the work
yourself
I am on the same page as you I believe I
I think there's something to be said for
all of the different Pockets blocks
dogmas uh all the information out there
whether it's religion or science
um and I feel like my opinion is I feel
like things that are spiritual are just
things that's that science hasn't proven
yet what does religion or spirituality
get right then religion gets a couple
things very very right a couple of them
that science gets wrong and a couple
that science gets right spiritual
Traditions especially the Eastern
mystical ones
but but also a Christian mystical
um you know it's like Benedictine monks
kind of thing um get right that space
and time and the physical what we call
the physical world is not the
fundamental reality I think they're
right about that
that there is something beyond space and
time and
until recently science got that wrong
scientists assume that space-time was
fundamental like Einstein thought space
time was fundamental for example
uh and of course I admire Einstein but
you know I was a scientist you have to
to admire them but then move forward and
now physics has moved forward best
physicists are now saying space-time is
not fundamental they say space time is
doomed so their science is converging
with spirituality and saying that
space-time is not fundamental so so
that's something that that
um spirituality has gotten correct I
would say another thing that
spirituality has gotten correct is that
they say that reality
whatever it is beyond space-time they
will use the word God and so forth or or
Brahman or or
whatever it might be they'll say that
that transcends any description we can
give it's beyond any language so that
the language that we use should not be
taken as
the thing is just a pointer so the the
Buddha say the finger pointing to the
Moon is not the Moon
right and and and so I think that they
get that right and if scientists who say
we We've Got a Theory of Everything
and and they believe that then they've
got it wrong I think most scientists who
say we have a theory of everything it's
with a wink and a nod they they know
that it's not the final Theory of
Everything But there are some who who
think that they are looking for the
final theory of everything and and there
I think they're wrong and I think
they're wrong because of girdle's
incompleteness theorem
or this guy named Kurt girdle proved
around 1930 that uh basically anything
that you can write down precisely
um and is powerful enough to for example
be able to do arithmetic with it then
there will he showed that there will
always be things that are true that
cannot be stated in that language that
they can't can't be proven that I'll put
it can't be proven in your theoretical
language so the notion of Truth
transcends the notion of proof and
therefore the notion of scientific
theory and that means that there's an
unbounded intelligence as far as the way
I think of it there's this unbounded set
of truths and therefore there's
unbounded intelligence Beyond any
description that we could give in
language or scientific theories and so
the spiritual Traditions have said that
for a long time without you they said
our language would never do anything but
point to the reality now science has
caught up with that I think most
scientists really understand this so you
can see that there is this convergence
then the question is what is beyond
space-time what what how should we talk
about that intelligence even though we
know that ultimately our descriptions
aren't hit
nevertheless
descriptions aren't completely
irrelevant so that's the interesting
tension
fascinated by the idea that space-time
is doomed I'm maybe we back up
back up and like try and unpack like
this reality first like I'm curious
about this what is the reality Earth
this experience at this point in time
and then I want to understand like what
is our our human reality what is this
experience from a physical body so maybe
start with this reality that we were in
let's try to answer that question off to
say you know what framework that I'm
using for and I'll give you an answer
from a different framework so if I and
I'm not saying these Frameworks are
correct I'm just saying these are the
Frameworks that I use to think about
this kind of thing so one is the
evolutionary framework right so if I
just put on a hard-nosed evolutionary
biology kind of point of view what most
people think that entails is that there
is a real physical world there are real
physical organisms they evolve and they
reproduce and when your body dies that's
it that's that's the standard view of
most of my colleagues my own work with
my my um collaborators caitan prakash
many you seeing Robert prentner
several Brian Marion and Justin Mark a
bunch of us have been working on this
we've realized that when you look at the
mathematics of evolutionary theory
it entails that our perceptions are not
telling us the truth the probability
that we've been shaped to see reality as
it is is zero and it's a it's a clean
theorem of that of that theory and that
means that even though Darwin when he
came up with a theory was thinking about
a real physical world with real physical
objects and animals and so forth
in fact this is more like a virtual
reality what what evolution gave us from
this point of view is not a window on
the truth it gave us a headset a VR
headset to play the game of life and you
know if you to play a game in VR if you
had to toggle voltages in a computer to
play the game good luck you would lose
against someone who had a nice little
headset that knew showed you how to like
drive a steering wheel to you know to
drive a car or something like that turn
the steering wheel to drive a car so if
if from an evolutionary point of view we
were shaped with senses that guide
adaptive Behavior Keep Us Alive long
enough to reproduce period
they don't show us the truth so
Evolution also agrees that space-time is
not fundamental it's just a data
structure is just a headset
so so that's one perspective on things
then it agrees with what the physicists
are saying physicists now are saying
space time isn't fundamental
by the way Evolution doesn't tell us
what is
right it only tells us that we're seeing
through a VR headset but evolutionary
theory does not have the power to give
us a hint about what's beyond the
headset right it's really interesting
now the physicists they've got they have
used the mathematics of quantum field
Theory
uh uh and general relativity together
to discover that space-time is not
fundamental but there they have tools
that allow them to go beyond space-time
and they're doing it
so in the last 10 years they so this is
fairly recent they have discovered
structures called the amplitohedron
and cosmological polytope and and the
deepest structures is something called a
decorative permutation so
yeah these are like they're just if
you've seen the movie 2001 the Space
Odyssey but there's the the
scene where there's just the monolith
that's sitting there and all the monkeys
are pounding on it and screaming and you
know they know it's significant but they
don't know what the significance is
right and and so that's where we are
right now we have these these static
monoliths Beyond space-time there's the
geometric structures like the
amplitohedron and the decorated they're
just sitting there and and my feeling is
that it's amazing we've discovered the
the physicists have discovered these
monoliths but there's no notion of
Dynamics they're just geometric objects
or these mathematical structures like
the decorated permutations so so that's
as far as the physicists have gotten
Beyond space-time you know are they on
other planets moons are they others are
they truly speaking of structures are
they are they uh frequency structures in
space-time this is hard to do but you
have to think entirely outside of
space-time so the think of space-time as
just your headset and on the other side
of the headset are these structures okay
so it's you you think well okay space
time well that goes out billions and
billions of light years there's
trillions of yep that's just all of that
is just your headset you have to think
all the way beyond that and there are
these structures so kind of like what's
beyond infinity
exactly right exactly right where the
infinity is just in your head when I was
a kid was I was looking up and going
what's at the end of this it's Infinity
it doesn't what's out there and you just
answered it hats off to the physicists
many many who have contributed to this
but the amplitudehedron was um Nema
arkani Hamed and his collaborators and
uh Juan Maldives and Nema have been have
worked on the cosmological polytope and
others so I'm just mentioning a few
there's many many brilliant people many
of them are at the institute for
advanced study at Princeton um where a
lot of this work has been done and the
the you know the answer to human was
only published in 2013. that's less than
10 years ago so so this is fairly new
and and so that's no surprise that not
too many people know that there are
these structures Beyond space-time and
and many brilliant people have exactly
your question which is how do you put
these structures inside space-time where
where are they and and that's a good
question because it really
points out to know they're entirely
Beyond space-time you have to imagine
that all of space-time as big as it
might seem
is nothing but a little headset
and on the other side of the headset is
in a much more complicated realm
um and but all we know about the realm
from physics is there are these
structures like the monoliths in 2001
and so and no notion of Dynamics now
what I'm working on is the third answer
to your question about you know what's
the reality I'm proposing it's
consciousness
and my my colleague uh colleagues Manish
Singh and caitan prakash and others are
working with me on this Robert prentner
where we're working on a mathematical
model of consciousness
qua Consciousness so it's Consciousness
not as like
an emergent feature of brain activity or
an emergent feature of some artificial
intelligence circuitry or software it's
on it's fundamental like the spiritual
Traditions have said Consciousness is a
fundamental reality and it turns out
with mathematics you can make that
precise and what I'm working on right
now is saying okay a dynamics of
consciousness
outside of space-time
is in fact a dynamics that gives rise to
the structures that the physicists are
finding like the decorated permutations
and we have a paper that we're about to
submit in in less than two weeks for
publication which we actually show that
mapping from dynamics of conscious
agents into decorative permutations so
we actually can do a mathematical model
that says again this is science and so
of course we're probably wrong but but
but but at least it's precise here's a
mathematical model of dynamics of
Consciousness and this Dynamics gives us
the decorated permutations which you
guys have found Beyond space-time so
this might be the Dynamics behind your
monoliths and the Dynamics of
Consciousness so that's sort of fun
that's super exciting I mean you must be
like I mean publishing is so it takes so
long and there's so much vetting out and
you guys like to break each other's
theories down and that's the sort of
your it's like a quite an aggressive
process to get to publishing so congrats
for sure on that I'll be excited to hear
uh here and see what that um it comes
from that so it's like an interface then
it's so this there's a there's a human
experience that is some kind of virtual
reality game and that Consciousness is
above it and I'm going to share a story
and I hope it doesn't diminish me in any
way although I'm not sure where I'm at
anyway as I by no means a scientist or
anything but um I I I took a psychedelic
mushroom and I was dropped into this
very deep experience where it felt like
I went to what I would call Baseline
reality which I saw myself as a waveform
I just was a waveform and
um there was a whole experience there
where I was cold and then uh the
information was like oh cold is just
something that you're experiencing as a
human just to experience it but it's
just waveform intersecting and that's
really all it is and just go ahead cover
up if you're cold that's what you're
supposed to feel it's just an experience
it's just here to be felt just like a
mango is just meant to be tasted it's
just it's just some sort of intersection
of information and
um and then what I had to agree to to
build like this I in my this is my
experience build the construct to get
back to being human because I had to
agree to the mind and like me agreeing
to the mind was me agreeing to the lie
that this was real that this situation
is real and that that then showed me
that this is why we forget so much
because if you were to remember
everything you would know that this
wasn't real and you'd be out of the game
and so
um I I'm just I I'm I'm just curious
what your thoughts are around that and
how that correlates with your research
and um all of your scientific
developments does that even does that
even make sense it makes complete sense
it turns out these decorated
permutations like what when you look at
it from our dynamical point of view
which which is a new point of view what
those decorated permutations are
literally coding for out of the
frequency various frequencies of
interactions of conscious agents we the
technical term we use are the
communicating classes so the
consultations but the size of the
communicating class is effectively
telling you something about his
frequency the frequency of the the
fastest frequency you could possibly
have and so it really is these
structures that the businesses have
found and that we're now coming to from
the point of view of Consciousness are
really these concise descriptions of all
the kinds of frequencies and in in our
model there's an infinite variety of
these frequencies an unlimited variety
of these frequencies and we they're all
captured in these things we call Markov
polytopes and the structure of these
Markov polytopes so what's interesting
about it as well is in our theory of
conscious agents Whenever two agents
interact
or even if you just have two agents just
sitting there not interacting they
instantiate a new combined agent
so that's just a part I didn't plan that
but that's what the math just says so
when we wrote down our mathematical
model of conscious agents it just says
if you have n agents then there is one
agent as well which is their combination
which means if I have like an infinite
number of Agents just like one two three
four so accountable Infinity of Agents
then if I look at all the combinations
it's there are you know there's a lot of
combinations right yeah well it turns
out there's so many it's a new kind of
infinity yeah so the first is called a
left zero the smallest Infinity is the
integers but when you look at all the
possible combinations of the Agents of
those
it's a higher Infinities called alif1
then if we go look at their combinations
go to alif2 this is called cantor's
hierarchy and so what we what we our
Theory Of Consciousness is saying is yes
all the agents are one agent
but our mathematics will never be able
to describe that one agent because we to
describe it we'd have to do all these
combinations and look at them and then
and cancerous hierarchy goes up to
Infinity so what's interesting is
our Theory says there is one deep
Consciousness the one yeah and no
scientific theory at least
can can ever go there because of
Canter's hierarchy we can go to level
trillion you know so we've got to the
trillionth level of cancerous hierarchy
which would be fabulous but that we have
infinitely far to go so that's right so
this gets to what the spiritual
Traditions are saying is that
any Theory or anything that we say can
only be a pointer and here the
mathematics is saying explicitly this
Theory Of Consciousness tells you that
there's one Consciousness one ultimate
Consciousness but it also tells you that
the theory itself can only be a pointer
it can never fully describe
by a long shot that one Consciousness
and yet it may be the best tool we have
so it's also an infinite game
that's right and we're not separate from
it even though we can't describe that
infinite intelligence that infinite one
we are it so we can be it
right know it by being it but we can't
know it intellectually we can't know the
water that we're swimming in as a fish
we just can't we can't touch it we keep
trying to touch it see it feel it we
can't know it we don't even know what to
look for maybe to some degree
um but the one thing about that
experience too that was so interesting
was that there was I had not only an
awareness to agreeing to the mind but
there was an awareness to the waveform
like that wasn't the mind and wasn't
this construct
and so what
I don't know if I've asked this maybe
what is the Consciousness or the one
what is the what is the overlay
of Consciousness well I think that the
spiritual Traditions that that encourage
us to sit in silence and let go of all
thoughts
are and just be are giving us our best
insight into that deep unlimited
intelligence that we really are so when
we yeah when we sit and meditate but
thoughts are going through our head then
we're still trapped in the mind as you
said we had to agree to take on the mind
so you're still trapped in your mind and
that means that you're shielded off
from this infinite intelligence yeah and
it's scary to let go of mine because it
has its own frequency in some sense it
has its own life that it wants to keep
oh I was very scary I was afraid I was
afraid I was I was gone I was like I was
I'm gone
yeah exactly right and and so that same
fear comes up in meditation it takes a
long time to learn to completely
go into inner silence not just exterior
silence and you know no movement of the
body but no movement of the mind just
complete silence and when you do that
then you are that infinite intelligence
and
girdle tells us girdle's incompleteness
theorem tells us that even though you
are that infinite intelligence you can't
describe it the in your description will
only be a pointer so as a scientist and
as a human being what I try to do now is
to practice of course I want to think
clearly and and rigorously and and read
the scientific literature and the
spiritual literature that's that's a
mind kind of thing it's it's all
Concepts in mind and so forth and then
take time where I literally stop and say
now it's time to set that all aside and
just be in utter silence and be that
infinite you know intelligence and then
go back and forth so some what you were
experiencing with the mushrooms is
something that eventually I think we
need to be doing in our everyday life
yes I I agree to the minds now now I
agree
to let go of it all together
and and go back and forth and I bet the
best advances in both science and
spirituality will come from those who do
both if you're just in the mind you're
trapped in the limited intelligence if
you're just in the infinite intelligence
you can't help others who can't right so
there's some for some reason we need
both
and
so in my own science what I do is I of
course do my studies and think hard but
then I when I have a problem that I'm
interested in I'll I'll just stop and be
absolutely quiet and see what comes out
of the infinite intelligence is there
something that you have a striking
memory of that you were like boom there
it is
the map to the decorated permutations
from Consciousness for example we came
out of the silence so it's it's
and I'm not saying everything that comes
out of it is right the first time but
I'm saying it but it gives you Insight
so this is not some kind of
infallibility kind of thing but it is
saying that there is this deeper
intelligence and we can tap into it um
as we if we learn to but but the
decorated permutations are one and and
by the way when I when I came up with
the idea of decorative permutations
being mapped from these markovian
um I had it under a certain concept and
my colleague caitan prakash then
tightened up the concepts so it was it
was it took the two of us to put
together the final definition of it so
so that's the way it works there's
there's the the unbounded intelligence
that leads to some insights and then
there's the cleaning it up with the the
work of math caitan's mathematician for
example so it goes both ways feels like
there's sort of these Dimensions maybe I
I don't even know if dimensions are the
right word but I'm wondering if
every level of new awareness can be
connected through a thread is there a
way that they all connect or is perhaps
like as you're describing this space
where there's nothing is there is the
next
Dimension is the next reality is the
next growth or Evolution or awareness is
it an ineffable kind of reality where
it's not based on Words it's based on in
the mind it's based on feeling or a
different mechanism
yes so one thing that comes out of this
theory of conscious agents
again one as I said before it it points
to the fact that the fundamental
consciousness of ultimately transcends a
new description so that's that's the
fundamental thing but given that we're
describing here's what it says is a good
description
it says that there's an unbounded
variety of different kinds of conscious
experiences
one thing so if you think about it if I
ask you you know think or imagine a
specific color that you've never seen
before
but nothing happens right
or imagine a five dimensional like
concretely imagined a five-dimensional
space nothing happens yeah
and yet we know that mathematically
these things are possible so so there's
there's a whole range of conscious
experiences and conscious imaginations
that that we know are in principle
possible and we can't do it concretely
so
and then there's going to be a whole
range of so they'll be conscious agents
I would imagine who don't just see like
three dimensions of space in one
dimension at a time why not have a
million dimensions of space what you
know our particular headset of three
dimensions of space one dimensional time
maybe one of the um the the low quality
the lower on the totem pole kind of
thing we're you know we only get three
dimensions of space one of time why not
50 billion dimensions of space and or
why not something that transcends the
notion of Dimension altogether maybe
it's just topological or something even
far more General as much as our
imagination can expand to imagine the
possibilities they transcended the real
possibility is transcend that and so for
me then it's the mathematics then that
helps me
it really
has helped me to open up my imagination
to the other possibilities
so that's where you have your
imagination you put your ideas into
mathematics then the mathematics comes
back and says here are some new
possibilities you didn't even think of
like with Einstein
he had the imagination that if I when he
was thinking about gravity if I was in
an elevator he said and I'm falling but
I'm standing on a weight scale
to measure my weight I would weigh zero
if the if the elevator was in free fall
that was his big idea and he said it was
like the happiest thought of his life
was that insight and a few years later
with lots of work in mathematics he came
up with the theory of general relativity
which coded for that idea
well so now that so his idea led to the
math
but then his math a year later a guy
named schwartzfield
came back to Einstein and said your math
says that there's something that we now
call black holes
Einstein didn't know that he didn't like
it
he had to expand his imagination
um and it took him decades because he he
was against black holes even though his
own Theory said so here's how
imagination leads to math and then math
will prod your imagination to open up to
wider so there's the cycle but but I
would say then that
um the varieties of possible conscious
experience are endless
and
we should really take to heart that we
can't even imagine a specific new color
so we shouldn't let the poverty of our
imagination limit us
to the idea that there's this infinite
right and you get a touch of it with
mushrooms and other
um psychoactive drugs you get a touch of
the doors of perception opening to all
the is all the sexually called I believe
to all these other possibilities and and
uh so so here's science and the drugs
and and and logic all make the same I
think point do you are psychedelics do
you think a tool a helpful tool I'm
actually just curious from your
perspective if there's something that
plays into helping to get insight or if
you even believe it believe in the
information that comes through people
with these experiences well my attitude
is that there's probably like like
everything there's probably some real
good stuff there and there's probably
some nonsense right but you see that in
scientific theories you see that in
spiritual Traditions so I would say the
same thing is going to be true in the
these studies with um with psychoactive
drugs and so so my guess is that again
we we should go in with an open mind but
also a hard nose sure and and and do the
experiments and and corroborate them
across subjects and then get
mathematical models and and then and not
jump to conclusions but again on the
other hand if if an experience gives you
an intuition and an idea
you should just you know pursue it and
see where it goes
um freely eventually as a scientist I
want it to be rigorous and mathematical
and then come back and and you know like
Einstein's equations came back and
taught Einstein well you know you didn't
know about black holes but they are
black holes you didn't believe in them
they're there so you also didn't like
quantum entanglement so you know yes
exactly right and and this I guess just
this week the Nobel committee announced
the prize for
um the the scientists who
um really experimentally confirmed the
prediction of quantum theory that what
we call local realism that that local
realism is false
so the idea that the physical objects
have in space and time have definite
values of position or momentum or spin
when they're not observed and that those
definite values have influences that
propagate no faster than the speed of
light so the first one is called realism
that they have definite values and the
second part is is locality that means
that they influences propagate no faster
than the speed of light everybody has
assumed that local realism is true
and it's false stop it that just came
out yeah they got the Nobel Prize for it
so that means that it's not just come
out it's been a prediction of quantum
theory
for many many decades it's been known
for many many decades it was so
stunning
that
it took decades for us to finally get
the experiment and that convinced the
scientific community that this is true
Hauser did this I think he got the Nobel
Prize he was one of the first to do is
but it took many many years after he did
so people would say well there's got to
be a loophole they would find a loophole
so let's close that loophole and after
they had like for decades oh yeah and
here's a loophole and close it close it
and when they finally it closed all the
loopholes Nobel committee said okay
we may not like it local realism is
false and these guys deserve the Nobel
Prize for shutting the door on saying no
to that
what is it saying about like the table
let's say that it's not really local
that what is its fundamental reality
then it means that it doesn't have a
position when it's not observed
it doesn't matter it's not observed
right okay if you don't have a position
when you're not observed then you're not
there
I mean I am with you I totally and when
I do think about that right and it's
when I listen to you it's like when
you're in a virtual reality or when
you're in a video game and you're
looking you're only populate like it's
just populating what you see you don't
see behind you you don't see on the
other side of the planet you don't see
so when people talk about crazy things
like Flat Earth and whatever I'm like
I'm like it's highly more likely that
we're just in a virtual reality and the
reason why everything looks flat is
because we're just in a virtual reality
like it can't make sense because we
don't have enough information right now
we think there's this ball and this
thing and it's existing and that's more
likely to me than anything and so what
is then creating our reality
um example that you gave was just right
if I'm playing Grand Theft Auto and VR
and I look over and I see a red Camaro
well there's no red Camaro in the
computer that's running the game so I'm
just rendering the red Camaro when I
look
and then when I look over there and I
see a a green Mustang well now I'm
rendering a green Mustang and the red
Camaro no longer exists it doesn't have
a position it has no momentum no spin
nothing it doesn't exist so that's why
local realism is false because the space
time and objects that we see are all of
VR so we render them as we need and so
that's why there's everything it changes
everything and this is where it gets
personally kind of freaky
because that means your own body
is just an avatar
and it means that I only have neurons
when someone looks
so neurons don't exist when they're not
perceived
my hand doesn't exist when it's not
perceived
but when it's perceived then is
perceived as an icon in in some
conscious interface so so that means
that I'm all for Neuroscience by the way
I'm a cognitive neuroscientist
investment some of my best friends and
colleagues are neuroscientists we need
more money for Neuroscience not less but
the reason we need more money is because
we thought neurons are the reality I
looked in the brain I see neurons that's
the reality is far more complicated
those neurons are merely pointers to a
much deeper World Beyond space-time
that's far more complicated than neurons
and so we're going to have to reverse
engineer neurons to really understand
our brain icon that we see when we look
inside of brains so we need more money
for Neuroscience because their job is
far more difficult than we ever imagined
it's basically going to have to
understand this whole network of
conscious agents that gets projected
into our interface and looks like
neurons in that projection yeah so so
you can see it's it's quite complicated
but but it gets it's really freaky when
you think about well I don't have a body
when it's not perceived so that then
gets to the heart of your question which
is okay what is doing all the rendering
what is rendering
the stuff and
of course the final answer is I think
it's beyond words
this is your question too right this is
my question and the best that we can do
right now in in the work that I'm doing
is to say we can model this
reality using the language of conscious
agents
and
we can then model with this network so
it's it's Network information Theory
it's a branch of mathematics using this
a network of conscious agents we can
build a model and we plan to do this
about how we create this headset how
does a set of conscious agents create a
space and time
um and physical object
reality headset as a interface to
represent its interaction with other
conscious agents so we have to build a
literal network of conscious agents to
that creates the headset and then what
we're going to do is turn that
Network and have it look at itself
when we have a look at itself
I expect that we will it will look like
brains and neurons we all dissolve well
it will give us what we see as brains
and neurons because that's our our
headset representation of all the
network of agents that are creating this
interface yeah so so that that'll be a
very interesting self-reflective kind of
science where we use a network of agents
to build our interface we turn the
interface on the network and then it
looks like the network then looks like
neurons to itself so what is the brain
what's the brain doing like what is this
what is this uh you know um buttery like
substance inside of this hard Pokey
shell that we call a brain
the brain is doing as much as that
Camaro does in the virtual reality um
game of Grand Theft Auto right I see the
Camaro when I look and when I don't look
the Camaro does nothing because it's not
there
so it has a loaded program in and of
itself is there some kind of a loaded
program like the Camaro knows it's gonna
it has parameters like the this car
handles really well it's really fast
where the green car is like kind of slow
but you know you can fit more people or
whatever it is like is there an uploaded
program in the brain that is already
there that limits us to some degree
that's a really important question
because that really will help to bring
this whole idea out so in the case of
the Camaro right where is the
information that knows about the the gas
in the Camaro and the speed of the
Camaro it's not in the Camaro right the
Camaro with just a bunch of pixels on
the so that's that's in something it's
entirely outside of the Camaro the
Camaro actually knows nothing about that
the Camaro is just what I see the
reality I'm interacting with is utterly
unlike a Camaro and that that reality
that's utterly unlike a Camaro has all
the information that is
behind what I call the Camaro and how it
behaves same thing with our brain the
brain has new information
because the brain doesn't even exist
when it's not perceived
there is this realm I'm calling it The
Realm of conscious agents that's utterly
beyond space and time and utterly beyond
the brain that has all the information
that has all the Dynamics and
we project that complicated Dynamics
into a relatively trivial structure that
we call the brain when we look at it
just like I project a supercomputer into
a Camaro when I look and see a Camaro
it's almost like the brain is a recorder
because even when you think about like
how reality how like Life Works you
follow patterns you know you grow up a
certain way and you attract a certain
relationship because of your
interpersonal like patterns whatever it
is there's very much a lot of patterning
going on and so this sort of follows
along so the brain can pick up on
whatever exists in this reality as a
pattern over and over and over again and
that can shift it's a big boat to turn
but you can you can shift that because
it's just sort of an ongoing patterner
but there has to be something that
started a pattern
yes and
that's that gets a to something even
deeper here and that is
that we if there's this one
infinite unbounded intelligence the one
Consciousness yeah in some sense what
you and I are are just Avatar
projections of it yeah and so it in that
projection see Consciousness itself is
outside of time
yeah and we're bounded in time
yeah so and it turns out when that turns
out to be a mathematical theorem in the
framework of our conscious age and stuff
it's easy for me to write down a
dynamics of Consciousness that has no
time in the sense of what we think of
growing entropy like Things Fall Apart
as time moves on things run down that's
the second law of Thermodynamics well
you don't have to have things run down
in this realm Beyond space-time
conscious agents can have a Dynamics in
which the entropy is constant but
anytime you take a projection of that
dynamics of consciousness
so you're losing information you're
projecting the the one this huge
unlimited one onto some final like
space-time headset
it's a theorem a trivial theorem to
prove that you will in the process
induce an arrow of time entropy will
increase as merely an artifact of the
projection so all of our patterns
even our sense of time
is not a fundamental insight into
reality right the patterns we're talking
about I started when I was five I had
these patterns with my parents and then
then this pattern with my relationships
and so forth well that's that's a fine
description in our space-time language
but ultimately
there's this deeper point of view in
which the very notion of time and
sequence
is not real it's an artifact of our
limited perspective
and so ultimately the healing I think
from all that patterning comes from
stepping out of it altogether
by going into silence so of course
Psychotherapy I've
spent time in Psychotherapy that kind of
dealing with our our issues and specific
things is very very important but
ultimately I found the the really deep
healing comes when we learn to let go of
our projection all together go into
ultimate silence and experience who we
are completely independent of our form
and then really deep healing takes place
there
yeah there's prophetic things that come
through that you could have never
imagined in that space because you're
not using your mind
that that's right and and yet it can
come back and give you good insights for
the mind and give you good strategies
for for ways to cope with life and and
act differently in the future so okay so
how I mean I guess a very common
question
um is about creating reality and you
have the ability to create your real
your own reality so how do you do that I
think that there's an infinite variety
of ways so you know I'm a geek but how
about someone who's an artist
or a musician or a dancer
um or who loves to write literature or
or make movies there are if you think
about it there's
Even in our little headset space-time
headset we see this incredible variety
of outlets for for Creative expression
and my guess is that
um that's the tip of a giant iceberg
that we can't even imagine just like we
can't imagine the specific color that
you've never seen before we can't
imagine so so the unbounded unlimited
Consciousness that you and I are
but we can't really see it right now
because we're we've that Consciousness
has chosen to project into a limited
headset to explore the this range of its
possibilities but outside this limited
range there is an unbounded range of
things to explore so we're we're just
kindergartners and little um sandbox
playing with the toys that we've got but
there is a lot more outside the sandbox
so creativity kind of takes you out of
the mind and allows for new things to
come through is kind of what you're
saying
absolutely and and I I would agree and
it comes both from of course immersing
yourself into something like immersing
yourself into the details of dance or
choreography or filmmaking but then it
also equally involves
stepping into utter pure silence and
both are required for the real creative
expression it's a dance between the form
and the formless as the spiritual
Traditions would say yeah there it is
coming in again all right let's take um
okay let's take uh going all the way
down to what is believed to be the
universe as a singularity
is that is that what everyone agrees
essentially or most people agree or
people around you do you agree with that
and if that's the case then then the Big
Bang like what happened like what it's
just like try and understand that from
your perspective and your opinion or
your research and then I'm just curious
like as an additional question is like a
singularity okay well there has to be
something around a singularity right
this is this just there's something
around there's always a next thing so
what could have been around a
singularity and what happened with the
big bang so so you're you're right
a important question so the standard
view from the physics of space-time is
that about 13.8 billion years ago the
Big Bang occurred and what happened
before that is um you know from the
business point of view
um an open question there's lots of
different attitudes about it my attitude
is going back to what I said earlier
about time is an artifact of projection
so we could have a Timeless dynamics of
Consciousness there is no increasing
entropy
any projection will give you
increasing entropy as an artifact so
that means that that the Big Bang itself
and the whole 13.8 billion year history
of our universe is not a deep insight
into reality it's it's it's
an accident of a projection it's not an
Insight it's an accident of projection
and so we're we don't have to be stuck
in that and we can actually have this
model we can actually model what's
beyond space-time like the physicists I
found the amplitudehedron and cosmologic
so we can go beyond space-time with
their models they're hoping to show like
especially with the cosmological
polytope something before the Big Bang
themselves so the physicists are already
looking for something that will that
will will go beyond it so what I think
goes beyond to do is this dynamical
model of conscious agents
and so that and that is as we talked
about
um
not just infinitely complicated but it
goes up all of cantor's hierarchy the uh
all the levels of infinity so when you
take that reality which is not just one
level Infinity it's an infinite number
of levels of infinity and each level is
infinitely more large than the level
before it so it's hard to wrap your mind
around now take all of that and try to
cram that into three dimensions of space
in one dimension of time there's no
surprise you get singularities because
there's so much to cram so that's why we
get these singularities if the big bang
and black holes and so forth It's we're
taking this infinite
complicated unbounded intelligence of
Consciousness and cramming it into a
four-dimensional data structure and the
data structure can't do it and that's
why we got these singularities so that's
where they come from
it's like I think about Newtonian
physics anything about Quantum Theory or
Quantum quantum mechanics and they don't
really Jive and it is there just a new
math a new like a completely new
arrangement of information
with each level of awareness or each
Dimension are dimensions even real like
what what are does that even come into
your work and what you're looking at is
Dimensions right so first I'll say what
the physicists are doing here so the
physicists are are saying that they can
go beyond quantum theory
and Beyond Einstein's special and
general theories of Relativity so so
um AR Kani Hamed for example Institute
for advanced study is very explicit
about that and if for those who are
interested and wants some beef
if you just Google Nema or Connie Hamed
a-r-a-r-k-a-n-i-dash-h-a-m-e-d and
Google his name and Harvard lectures
2019. or Harvard lecture one 2019. he
gave an entire course a semester-long
course at Harvard
telling the physics graduate students
about the new structures Beyond
space-time so and he's saying it
explicitly quantum theory is not
fundamental space-time is not
fundamental both quantum theory and
space time will arise he says
joined at the hip
from these deeper structures and in that
semester-long class he then takes the
students through and shows these deeper
structures like the especially the
amplitude is what he focuses on the
positive grass ammonium and the
decorative permutation so they really
focus on that but the idea is yes we can
go beyond space-time and what we want to
do then is to show how precisely
space-time and quantum theory arise as
projections of a far deeper Theory so
there Rises projections before deeper
Theory and then you know Newton arises
as a special case for example of
Einstein Newton Newton's Theory comes as
um as the speed of light goes to
infinity or is a special case of quantum
theory as so-called Planck's constant
goes to zero so we try to we don't throw
away our old theories we we love Newton
Newton's theory is wonderful Einstein
and quantum theory are wonderful they
were incredibly powerful tools and they
will remain powerful tools for a lot of
applications
and any deeper theory that we come up
with we want to show how
when we project it we get special cases
of the old Theory the old theory is a
special case of the new theory that we
have so that's what science tries to do
now some theories we just throw away
we've had theories uh you know caloric
and so forth in in the history of
science where there was nothing to say
it was just so wrong that we're not
trying to show that it's a special case
of our new theory that was just wrong so
that happens in science too
um but I think Evolution for natural
selection will also come out as again
um a special case so we'll have this
theory of conscious agents for example
in which there's no competition
there's no limited resources that's a
different reality if you're red and
tooth and Claw but when you take a
projection of it onto a space-time
interface then you get the illusion of
time you get the illusion of competition
and the illusion of limited resources
and competition so this whole thing is
an illusion of projection so I'm coming
back to when you said I think we'll go
between these two states of it's what it
sounds like you're saying is there'll be
this sort of perception that will like
anchor us in a time-space reality and
competition and all the other things and
then you go out of that and into this uh
more pure awareness state for lack of a
better word
um that uh where there's a different
reality a bigger reality and so I I say
that but really my question is is that
what happens when the next
Theory
is like what happens with the next
Theory I mean just the fact that this
the Nobel Peace Prize was given for
nothing being local I mean what is the
input what are the implications of that
and how do we move forward as humans
well it was a normal physics Nobel Prize
in physics the good news for scientists
is that girdle's incompleteness theorem
tells us that there's infinite job
security
we can never get a theory of everything
and so my theory of conscious ages with
my team is absolutely not the final
Theory of Everything it's the next baby
step so I so so I'm sure I want to see
it in my lifetime where my theory gets
completely transcended and there's some
deeper theory that shows that my theory
is a special case and this will go on
forever
um so in principle because that's what
it means for this unbounded intelligence
to be the final reality it means that
theory building
um is
um a really good job to go into because
you're never going to
be unemployed
so what's the drive then what is the
ultimate goal
that is a great question
but the honest answer is I don't know
and I'll just speculate it may be there
are two directives of answers that I've
thought about and and then I'll say by
another problem with both of those
directions so One Direction would be to
say
um
the Ultimate Reality is love
but
to really love
um
you need something to love and so the
one
intelligence projects itself into
multiple avatars
so that it has a chance to
learn to love and to practice love
so that's one idea so the reason for
making all this variety of headsets is
for the one to learn to love that's an
interesting direction that a friend of
mine Perry passaro suggested that to me
as we were talking about your question
um and that and again I'm not saying
well I'll say why I think
there's a deeper problem here but the
other is to say you know uh this is more
from the exploration side of things is
to say well girdles incompleteness
theorem tells us there's an infinite
variety of mathematical structure to
explore infinite
it's endless and that means there's an
infinite variety of conscious
experiences to explore infinite right
yeah and so maybe that's what so
Consciousness is exploring all of its
infinite possibilities and saying let me
try on this headset and maybe you know
three dimensions of space one
dimensional time which is what we've got
is a fairly
rudimentary right this is why we think
of ourselves as sort of the exalted we
if we could look at the big picture we
might realize no no this this is a
particularly simple headset try the 50
billion Dimensions headset well you
think that chocolate tastes good hang on
a second hang on a second exactly
exactly full body orgasm with this
chocolate here you go that that's right
or you thought orgasm was something wait
till you see this
right right
one is about
um just the the fun of exploration but
in talking about this with a friend of
mine Annika Harris
um
who's uh you know she's got a book
called conscious and she's she's she
thinks very deeply about Consciousness
um
and what I was talking with her just a
week or so ago over lunch about this
very topic she said you know that that's
effectively she said it's too Romantics
she met too anthropocentric
those both of those kinds of
explanations may not they may be the
best kind of ideas that we can have from
our point of view of avatars in space
and time but they and and they're good
but but we shouldn't cling to those
either the I mean there's probably
something even far deeper than that and
I I think her point is well taken but
nevertheless I think it's worthwhile to
put out these romantic ideas these
human-centric ideas
if for nothing else to have them as
foils so that we can go deeper and find
deeper answers to that to your question
when we go to the first one about love I
think you also mentioned something about
there being a lot of basically it seems
harmonic and peaceful so how do you know
love if you don't have the opposite are
polarity is fundamental
to Evolution even if it means just the
next level of awareness like how do you
know this without that right that's
that's a really good question what why
does the unbounded intelligence decide
to drop into these smaller Realms of
polarities right because in some sense
there is no opposite of love
what love just is and yet here we have
um what we might call clinging and not
clinging which is sort of our our our
polarities that we call love
um in the human sense although there is
that you know a Mother Teresa kind of
love that isn't the kind of clinking
right there is that deeper kind of love
that that is possible but much of what
we call love is not it's it's more
clinging or or
you know or eventually running away from
somebody
so sometimes they do so yeah sometimes
and and I
that is an incredibly deep question
which is
why does
the unbounded intelligence
plunge itself into these avatars
the I mean the kinds of things we
sketched about
learning to love and exploring all the
possibilities
somehow I feel like I'm up against the
limits of my current abilities with that
question uh just that's that's as far as
I've gotten this and I don't know how to
go further which except just to go into
silence and and see what comes out of it
that's beautiful I love the honesty of
that that's that's um that's the right
answer okay to kind of like sort of wrap
up at least what's going on within our
realm right now that seems like
something kind of interesting that I'm
just curious what your thoughts are and
how it will play into all this is just
um AI you know I know that that was
something of interest to you initially
um going into artificial intelligence to
understand things so
um do you think that that you know what
what's the best case scenario that
what's the worst case and you know how
could that help us in our Evolution and
is AI actually our Evolution like is do
you believe that Consciousness can be uh
do you think that an artificial
intelligence can adopt Consciousness and
can have one right so the standard way
that that question is asked is from a
physicalist framework most of my
colleagues who are thinking about it are
saying space and time is fundamental
matter is fundamental matter is not
Consciousness it matters not conscious
itself but the idea is if you have
the right kind of complexity in the
interactions of matter so the right kind
of neural circuitry or the right kind of
artificial intelligence software somehow
the unconscious ingredients will give
rise to consciousness
so integrated information theory for
example is one Theory along that line
where they think that they some there's
if a system has some kind of functional
property they call Integrated
information
the right kind of integrator information
then it will give rise to Consciousness
Consciousness or orchestrated collapse
of microtubule States or something
called a global neuronal workspace so
there's different ways where you have
some substrate now integrated
information Theory people can say well
they don't have to assume space time but
they're going to assume some substrate
the substrate that's not conscious yeah
and if it's not physics what is it that
they haven't said but anyway
so
they're trying to say that the
artificial intelligence Consciousness
would emerge from unconscious
ingredients
and I'm saying that the physicists are
telling us that those ingredients don't
even exist when they're not perceived
they can't give rise to Consciousness
because they don't have the power local
realism is false so the Nobel Prize is
given this week local realism is false
it's time for arthritis of Consciousness
to recognize that local realism is false
physical objects do not exist when
they're not perceived so they could not
create Consciousness so that version of
you know artificial intelligence giving
rise to Consciousness is dead
if you can't work nevertheless I think
that if we we can get at it from a
different angle okay our
perceptions of space and time and
objects is a user interface to this
realm of conscious agents in our current
in my current theory so right now
um
I see through a zoom screen I see pixels
of your face those pixels are not
conscious or unconscious yeah so I also
see pixels of of a wall behind you and
your face has given me insight into your
Consciousness I'm getting an insight
into what you think what you're worried
about what you're excited about
but the pixels on the wall give me no
insight into Consciousness so
my interface gives me portals into
Consciousness the good portals are
things we call human bodies or my cat
the cat body is a fairly Good Portal
into some Consciousness not as good as
human and enhance is a worse portal a
microbe is even worse and by the time we
get down to rocks and so forth the
portal is closed I'm always interacting
with Consciousness but my interface has
to give up that's what interfaces do
they're dumbing things down so if at
some point they just have to throw up
their hands and say I can't tell you
more about the conscience Consciousness
is far too complicated I'm just going to
show you a rock there is consciousness
by the way it's not that the rock is
conscious
right I'm not saying the rock is
conscious the rock is just my symbol so
the rock is my perception behind that
symbol behind outside of space and time
there's Consciousness I'm interacting
with and the best I can do is come up
with a rock that's just my application
got it
so so that's where we're stuck so that
that means if we can understand how
these portals work if we understand so
we know one way that we can make new
portals into Consciousness we do there's
one way we know how to do it it's very
low Tech okay it's having kids oh okay
right every time you have a kid you're
building up a new interface of
Consciousness right do you have kids I I
have a a daughter and three grandkids oh
wow so it's the sister has four or
fourth on the way so I'll have to live
through those guys probably
congratulations
so so
suppose that we understand this notion
of portal right what's going on here
that allows me to have access to your
Consciousness not complete but but
genuine access yeah and vice versa
whereas it's less to a cat and less to
an aunt right the portals if we
understand that our user or our
perceptual interface space and time is
an interface that way and these portals
and I think we can I think there's no
obstruction mathematically once we do
that then we should be able to engineer
new portals and it may turn out that
when we do that
some of the portals will have will look
like artificial intelligences
but it won't be that
unconscious
matter somehow gave rise to
Consciousness no it will be that
conscious agents
learned how their interface worked and
reverse engineered their interface to
open up new portals into already
existing consciousnesses but we're
already there
the technology may look like artificial
intelligence would probably look like a
lot of other things too once we really
understand this so my attitude is yes we
will eventually be able to create new
portals not just the old-fashioned way
through having kids but we'll be able to
do it technologically
and um
but it will not be unconscious matter
creating Consciousness it'll be
Consciousness opening up new portals
into itself yeah do you think that we'll
have a extraterrestrial
um portals available to us in our life I
think that you know there's the the
famous question of you know where are
they where are all these
extraterrestrials I mean we can keep
looking for them we are sorry where are
they well Consciousness is all around us
we have a headset on right so we're
looking inside we have a headset on
they're all around us and we're looking
like this
that's right I'm looking I can't where
are they they're they're all they're all
around us and so the the true search for
extra so now I'm not saying that we
won't find life at other planets we we
may and that's that's perfectly fine but
but that will still be a trivial limited
amount compared to what's all around us
all the time and this wall of Optimus by
our headset but once we get these
portals then our our true search for
extraterrestrial life won't just be
extra pressure it'll be extra space time
outside of space and time
wow
we have so much to learn well thank you
so much man there's um so many big
things have been happening which is very
exciting and yet it's only scratching
the surface on the infinite on the
infinite on the infinite exactly right
exactly right but that's what makes life
interesting absolutely humility is
entirely called for oh gosh wow I'm sure
that that's a remind a reminder reminder
in your work much of the time so
absolutely it was today for me so thank
you so much for your time and my mind is
blown wonderful wonderful almost as good
as mushrooms huh thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today I hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the Subscribe
button